hi hello hey episode 3 that's my turkey
impression yeah here in the US if you're
watching this it will have been
Thanksgiving a few days ago we're
recording this a couple days before
Thanksgiving before we are gonna go hang
out for the break if you're outside of
the US hopefully this makes your
Saturday fun regardless yeah
happy turkey day to everyone and even if
you're not in the u.s. you can still eat
partake in some delicious Turkey if
you're into that kind of stuff if you're
in Turkey if you're not into Turkey
what really Universal it's good but I
don't I wouldn't like your ham a veggie
head I'm joining me I'm not a veggie
head veggie head I'm just speaking those
are stocks so Anna Prosser who I work
with at twitch she's a veget
practically a vegan except I think she
eats like some milk anyway she said that
Thanksgiving is not great because she
can't eat like anything yeah and she
basically eats like cranberry sauce and
everybody talks about how great it is
and it's like not a thing she can enjoy
yeah cuz like potatoes usually mixed
with milk butter yeah butter butters and
everything so I think vegans really
suffer on Thanksgiving even squashy mix
butter in dude you put butter and
everything I can't think of a dish that
you wouldn't put butter in even beans
except for the cranberry sauce
creamy casserole with the crunchy bits
on top there yeah
french fried onions YUM people seem to
enjoy last episode dude was the best
episode ever although I was pretty upset
most of the time
tomorrow I'm saying and our UK editor he
was texting me like while he was
watching it a couple days after it aired
saying holy [ __ ] I didn't know jack did
that peekaboo thing or whatever he says
which is that the one when you smash the
kitchen table he smashed the kitchen
table I think I bring my headphones off
I think what's so cool because I where'd
that - I also read other people saying I
didn't know that Jack did these things
is it sounds like there's a decent
amount of change that he's doing like
his character based on how you play yeah
and I find that just super impressive of
the game in general yeah okay so I have
one heel so a couple things you can do
it you can do a reverse 180 apparent I
saw that in the Connery you I had done
it you don't have to do it as much in
this game as you do in other games but
show me if you like flick back and then
circle at the same time quick back in
circle it's so fast
yeah it's good okay cool it would have
been good for shooting Jack it's funny
though like it is good but I'm so bad
when things happen that I that I like
can't even remember how to heal which is
r1 yeah like I forget the simplest
things that's someone else saying if you
do the r1 heal and then press l1 right
after it to block it'll stop the heal
animations because it's so slow so you
can like do it faster oh okay so you
still heal you heal that you stop the
animation from taking for a second
that's smart do you remember what your
objective is right now okay so let's
talk about that I have a scorpion key
which I don't think I've unlocked
everything with I think I need one more
dog head so I can get outside yeah I
have a shotgun and I have bullets and I
know that the last dog head is in the
basement I'm pretty sure yeah
I don't remember where I am the section
room you're near the basement stairs
check do you have shotgun shells in your
say box or did you use those
I have ring I bring the chem fluid in
the Gunpowder oh if you're going in the
basement and the herb I guess there's
gonna be stuff down there actually well
I have a heal
do I need the knife no could I do that
cuz like when am I gonna stab anything
yeah okay so wait let me just talk about
this one more time I already have a
first aid so should I just made you Joe
it looks like the kombucha drink
sometimes okay should I just all right
should I just make bullets no because I
would say you have 26 bullets right now
I would say just what do you can mix to
get shot how do I make shotgun shells
press press when you back out of this
and press hit go - you are in torreón
combine convinced i don't know if you
can yet but there's probably an
ingredient that i'm can't think of i
think you're good now just to have those
things on hand okay you in mind you're
at yellow right now right so I can only
take like one more hit so I'm looking
for a dog right a dog head yeah you're
gonna the dissection room so and they're
definitely down here yeah but remember
you open up that shortcut to the right
that loops helpful or if the mole that
are molded are chasing you the mole dead
hi that's how some people pronounce it I
don't know if it's a mole dad or molded
check that shelf I don't think you got
it
[ __ ] them up Oh God
remember l1 box if victims do it
although you did a good job you did suck
led dick can't even get to becoming a
tree that shelf what to your left
I don't think there's somebody something
behind that wooden pallet down there
Kenner yeah sure are you full now close
to it close no no okay
Oh Lord I'm so scared I'm sorry wait
Oh God Oh God you got a lockpick over
here last time Oh God wears this daug
head this isn't the dissection room it
what I thought this was it I thought we
were successful in getting to the place
you got the score pinky here then you
ran back upstairs
I remember what happened whoo that's
another should I leave that for now wait
if you get it won't it stack on the
other one really take up another space I
don't know yeah no I should stack yeah
thanks you've also you can also if you
need to map those things to your hotkeys
I'm just like mentally coming to terms
with what's about to happen to me okay I
feel like I should make stuff because I
I'm like actually out of room what do
you think my inventory is full and I
could easily make a health and bullets I
wouldn't worry about bullets but maybe a
health would be nice cuz you're on
yellow okay you want to be safe no I'd
say don't heal yet see this actually
you're good that was good
so there's another hallway you go down
to your left that you passed earlier
that way that's where I came from
no no sorry yeah yeah that's right here
from no there's another thing to your
right up here
you were sprinting at the time cuz I'm
old I was chasing you Oh Lord so wait
you're saying I can go down here yes
you're right tonight yeah wait is it
going to the same place
no to go back to around the loop it's
back there
I don't think I have enough bullets
you've got a whole number two or nine
you're fine I'm scared
they've a dog bowl oh god what's that
you Oh God huh
that man would scare you yes sorry
what'd I miss
probably heal now wait check it yeah
whatever you're fine
I almost spilled my coffee all over your
phone I'm gonna move your phone the
music it's the music so the music like
got increased and it scared me like out
of the herb
oh here are one and then [ __ ] now it's
not good place to run run back to where
you came from they kill this guy press
right on your head you give your shotgun
hot bat or just make bullets it's up to
you I actually know this away from
shotgun shell you already [ __ ] this
guy up make bullets really quick go to
your combined screen you're happy in the
menu hey there you go
that's way better than using shotgun
shell well I think I just accidentally
made a [ __ ] another thing I mean you
can't help that it's gonna happen if you
walk by it
should I he'll give it one more hit I'd
say I don't want to die well you'll be
able to take one more hit before you do
so there was a thing in here yeah this
place is
[Music]
I mean there's gonna be mold in here I'm
pretty positive
my shotgun might be useful
just make sure you don't miss obviously
okay one thing I will say is you are
wasting of people it's when you're like
let them recover before you get a better
head at the shot at their head okay
[Music]
there's too many shy get my gun out yeah
I think you hit this guy already didn't
you just run back to where they started
I'm out of bullets
yeah I'm just straight about a bullet
you're fine there's just some CAD Mausam
what yeah just look around here for some
stuff
bottom I would use that sir
I [ __ ] him guy to you so much
I mean I feel like we have a great
relationship
[ __ ] I'm at a bullet on it's on so
you're gonna have to get stuff there
anyway so I'm out of bullets
I copy oh my [ __ ] god I'm out of
bullets
somebody do something it was really dumb
with me not to tell you keep your knife
Oh explain later yeah
ah did I get everything now there's a
door you didn't go through where is it
Oh Lord what am i doing chai just leave
I need a knife
oh that wasn't a scorpion or was it no
well maybe it was you don't need a knife
I'm just saying it helps to destroy a
box it's the good stuff listen
what am i doing is he gonna keep I have
no bullets I know don't worry about that
you don't have to kill everybody well
the [ __ ] is that I go out your left can
you go through the door over here where
you got the scar binky over here
wait yeah that way in the dog area dogs
I don't remember why yeah what do you
want there's a door there I don't know
well what about the other place I was
just at I'm just you don't I'm just
trying to you can't open that door right
now I thought it was a scorpion kid or
maybe I'm not I think it is I just
panicked check behind you no I need a
bullet hit I'm already down the legs
feed the wolf Mary I I don't know you're
gonna find him I used all of my bullets
kill a few of them no but
that's not enough there's stuff should I
eat that oh I can't kill that bobblehead
sorry I mean you could oh this isn't the
right door yeah okay I thought so is
that other one I can kill that other
thing now let's go kill it yeah I just
don't miss I never miss except for that
last time I'm back and I found two
bullets for your face wait hold on stop
here go go
turn around go to your right no I don't
like that's the dissection room I think
one of these of the dissection room okay
I think it's that one this should be
some in there yeah I forgot you were
being chased last time you were checking
oh yeah okay should be a lawyer can I
shut that yeah someone told me you could
shut doors okay it was ex Lucas I caught
the guy who keeps trying to escape I
locked him up in the leftmost
incinerator so he can't get away again
take him out when he's ready do you know
how to open the door just remember three
a's and a handprint do what you want
with his girl okay I feel like now I
don't have enough bullets oh you can
craft something new by the way a couple
new things hands handgun oh no I don't
have any gunpowder and what's that one
enhance enhance kombucha the 24 ounce
[Music]
listen I don't have like the firepower
to tab this fight okay take your time
with his next shot shooter the face good
book so alright did you check the other
side of the room like their their stuff
under the stretcher well that's when the
guy fell I don't think gunpowder right
there all right should I make bullets or
should I make shotgun you can't make
shotgun I see their hand got a more
enhanced handgun ammo how do you know
that oh good which one should I make
enhance Hanigan ammo great wait go up I
don't think you can you don't have chem
fluid for a regular uh [ __ ] that stuff's
healthy to save or worthwhile to save I
need bullets I can wait until something
comes at me but when something comes at
me I'm gonna have to make it as well did
you not have chem fluid up in the I
probably had a little bit I have to I'm
fine I'm gonna make it okay
uh what is this supposed to change to
the enhanced ammo no no the back just
hold l2 in the press triangle yeah
three A's and a handprint on the utmost
left is the one he said he put him in
yeah but that's okay wait the puzzle
there's a tag on that one in yourself
that you didn't see tomorrow tomorrow I
love ya tomorrow okay so this is a lock
with a puzzle there's the handprint I
need three is ha ha ha 3 is and the
handprint
[Music]
or you could spin around the circle oh
right
wait I did it wrong shut up I did it
wrong again Oh pulse what is that that
is dick oh no I'm in trouble I should
heal yeah
that wasn't a good fight you didn't want
me to make Bullock are you crazy yeah ah
[ __ ] me okay hold on you just thought
about stuff I didn't have no yeah yeah
what's that noise is it you know I'm not
squelching it's just you walking on that
stuff I think it's now you can get in
the locked door in that furnace room
that you were trying to go through but
there's a guy in there yeah but you
would you might as well just avoid him
so you don't use ammo again I would go
upstairs and scrounge
I'm gonna save how do I get home it's
like this way and then this way and then
upstairs
[ __ ] was there anything on that shelf
next to the door I don't know I'm
leaving I'm scared
I'm like playing like such a pansy
because I'm so afraid
no chem fluid I would use one of your
psychostimulants pop one of those right
now how long does it last like five
minutes no like a minute thirty seconds
I don't know okay I should save first
and I need a knife you don't need one
it's just helpful if you come across
boxes you don't want to shoot it got it
okay so I'm gonna want you're saying
don't use this but I don't have any
other chem fluid put that away for now
and then use psychostimulants up here or
downstairs but mainly up here what do
you mean up here like in this room yeah
like I'll see what I mean
no don't go back to the fireplace room
do you remember that is down yeah I
think there's a few things in there you
didn't get I have no [ __ ] ammo I mean
save first
oh right is she weighs something okay I
have no ammo it takes like an entire
round to kill one of those things
mine is the two that you missed
oops
[Music]
god the molded are so gross and they
walk really fast don't like regenerators
from before they do okay so you're
saying go I would pop the students now
really okay it's got a range on it like
it'll you'll see stuff through walls got
it okay it's going to consume these my
mom yes and I put forward this way yeah
yeah
there's something right into the door or
is that outside that's outside go that
safety hole through there yeah hopefully
bullets are fluid or something to do
with that
goody jacket yeah come on hey shotgun
shells go behind it sorry I've never
been on drugs before makes one of us
gun powder just crouch now and get nice
I'll bless you can I get in here yet no
need the croaky what's this I think that
might also be in the CRO room oh [ __ ] I
hope this was worth drugs to you yeah
and you'll get more of those it's just
this was helpful you mean that still
hasn't worn off I don't think so okay
where should I go upstairs maybe out of
the hole yeah oh there's something in
that room
oh this is no time for being coy with my
drugs it's already been longer than a
minute so you're fine
yeah what's over there oh it's the fake
shotgun oh that's I got tricked by drugs
can I go in here I don't think I can go
in this area try the other side yeah
that's a sneak might have worn off you
might as well look around here though
it's probably stuff you missed I don't
like going in here though I don't think
he can come out now if you went in the
basement that might be the trigger I
mean don't take my word for it but I
won't just scrounge like the shelves and
[ __ ] you can't make enhance handgun now
and you have two shotgun shells
bubble I was too stressed out to kill
that before yeah check down low - yeah I
feel like you should be crawling a lot
in this game oh wait there's handgun
rounds in that basket what I am so dumb
how did you see that Oh suck like the
icon to pick stuff up doesn't always
show up until you're looking right at
them right yeah he's probably crouched
on here - maybe under the bead
some wicker baskets oh if you take an
Abbott reefs towards your help what's
not did you check over here but maybe in
that trashcan I was a bit bit like
scared when I was yes scrounge in
what's that noise
the TV I don't think you went in that
corner American darkside ones that look
like that and a good-looking gentleman I
don't see any just like a man to lose
his head without his clothes on
excuse me sir this guy's got a Magnum
dong anything behind those paintings
what do you mean on the ground
I often hide stuff behind those nothing
oh cool that's actually this is pretty
pretty lucrative so far like the hallway
any other room sure yet I didn't go in
this but that's got a snake get rid of
your scorpions
you think yeah unless there's one down
here I'm the bathroom and the okay oh
god is that the window Jesus heads like
every time I came over here he was
following me so I was too scared
rude have I been in here that's the
bathroom I think he pretty well yeah you
scrounge this before he jumped out at
you okay so I haven't I have enough to
make some bullets not a lot of bullets
but some decent amount what's that
what's that she's that light was that
flickering light in the backyard
lockpicks are few and far between yeah
I've known your driver how valuable they
are I've only come across one and I've
been playing the game for a while yeah
okay cool
so what would you recommend
bookshelf no I haven't been over here at
all just a picture that's her waiter
we'll check that Evaline may 2nd 2014
it's just a football home and I was
thinking of I don't remember you talking
about it
I don't nothing
see ya for Lucas really like football or
Marguerite could have any any of them
the name of that book was they killed
him yes I saw that I couldn't think of a
good joke so I just didn't I just
literally repeated what it said well
yeah with the skill - okay um okay so
I'd like to get outside he's a third dog
head
so I'm gonna save again cuz we've had
some progress do your items first okay
so I've gotten a coin I'm gonna get rid
of it to them you don't need the
Scorpion key I don't do you I don't know
I'll bring it actually bring in case I
need to make more bullets you don't have
chem fluid to do that and I do not waste
your tron template what's come online
you can bring it but I'm telling you
like I have one strong bullet I don't
want to shock a guide you I'm just and
said do not use that because I know what
I feel like that's guiding me but
whatever okay but then you what have you
wasted and been pissed at me later for
letting you use it
oh no no winning with you no I don't
want to overwrite this double-standards
[Music]
new save data I can afford it this is
going better than last episode
reload y-you can reload your handguns
like once all in it that's it that's all
I have no it's not you had you picked up
handgun bullets in that wicker basket oh
sorry switch from your enhanced is that
what you think I should do well what
happens to my one bullet you'll keep it
but are you sure which order your
regular okay so now you'd have to reload
actually it wouldn't have mattered
anyway but at least not you have these
ten could save the good one for but my
advice is to not use it on the first
molded that attacks you like you could
just avoid evade them no you have to
kill them it's a survival cordoning no
this
it's Resident Evil 7 not one I need to
kill so there's something in here this
is the snake door you don't have that
wait so I shouldn't be going down here
there's no point no it's the furnace
room where you uh bungled that whole
thing so this way to the right
where are you precious and then is he
still in here or did it kill him
[ __ ] you and that noise get ready to use
the key
what key yes press X I use a dissection
repeat under that night yeah I don't
think you changed your name I think
you're good yeah
I think I just saw your like lungs fall
out of your mouth or not cuz I knew it
was there he's gotta be stuck here right
cut it I was gonna be a father
[Music]
oh he doesn't see me go so far that's
great that's ideal
oh he's gonna make him come alive isn't
he okay so okay so
oh god bless you anything else
grouchy okay I guess I'd go downstairs
yeah probably reload those shotgun
shells oh you got five of them is that
good mm-hmm should I use this or my
regular gun regular I mean it's up to
you but it's a fetus is that sock I
think it's like a bandage either way
it's not a fuse
Oh Lord
yeah didn't you guys play it for the
congrats on making your goal thank you
well you helped more shotgun shells I
always get excited when I see ammo but
what I really feel like it's saying is
your shits about to go down so it's like
not a good thing really though should be
breakable I don't want to go in there I
don't have any health and I don't have a
way to make health
like I can't only get hit like once
[Music]
[Music]
oh god that's gonna be where I have to
live you're in the dissection room go
there's little people in there hanging
out oh god please give me home and I
don't see anything
Oh God okay that's where the dog head
was but it's not there anymore and I
could check out the other half of this
room do you think that's a good idea or
not a good idea
I just thought cam fluid probably make
it healthy uh he's gonna come alive
isn't he
he's breathing poor deputy that was that
was it for now
there's gotta be other stuff in this
room who meathooks
mister was hot I don't actually want to
not look at him that's my problem I
scared myself by aiming I'm really
afraid because I know he's gonna come to
life I just don't know when is there
pizza under that table where you got the
chem fluid and everyone's a bag of meat
okay I'm gonna leave and he's gonna come
to life that was my guess I was wrong
[ __ ] that guy so much I just like don't
want to know
this place sucks
No Oh none of these options are good
that's a molded wall god what the [ __ ]
is that what are those black tights made
a mold mold act ight shy go down Oh God
what
that's a stupid option if I knew that's
what it X did I wouldn't have done it
why is that a thing time go downstairs
first do not do that yet it's a trap and
oh [ __ ] check around here first gotta be
stuff down here ok so I will get a snake
soon
oh god I have a headache from being
scared okay good
powder but I don't have enough chem
fluid snorted there's like not enough
chem fluid in the world
[ __ ] okay cool so I have an herb I can't
use a chem three gunpowder I can't use
five shotgun bullets yep it's where work
needs doing did you say that with a
southern accent you're in the hot seat
yeah flappers there's your last dog head
what could possibly go wrong
six I got it let's go mission success
[Music]
get it Oh big man God himself good yeah
I'm in trouble I need to heal it's a box
over there might have felt I think I
need to heal you don't have help well
he's [ __ ] walking really fast he
shoveled me
should I use my I'll get it on the next
clip Jake shoot him [ __ ] he's gonna kill
me he's gonna kill me
sure easy
[ __ ]
shut up jack
I like wasn't able to hit one dead body
into him not one yeah one at the
beginning I don't have enough like don't
let Jack's bizarre and deadly weapon
intimidate you
search your surroundings you may find
something to hold your own against him
Yugi press X I know I was reading hints
cuz I [ __ ] needed them
alright I have to read you all this [ __ ]
it's like two items
there was nothing down here I remember
that yeah so that was down here that was
it right you could make it now I was
making health because I needed it
gun powder no gunpowder downstairs that
I can't is now but still that's it great
[ __ ]
alright so I got one full health to kill
this guy like if I picked it up faster
shotgun shells in that box right
I don't behind you yeah you mean here
yeah but I don't know how to get to that
okay chainsaw
[ __ ] it's so hard to stun him let's do
what I feel like I'm [ __ ] super
unsuccessful kill me yeah you got to use
that quick turn around
she's the quick turnaround too but I
think you're focusing too much of the
bodies I don't you don't have to do that
I'm so bad at it yet alright let's try
this again
I didn't even get to heal on that one
like he killed me before I could heal
yeah boss it's a really tough battle and
I don't even think it started all right
so there's a shot there's a there's a
chainsaw but I can't get a knife out now
there's a chainsaw but I can't get to it
yeah yeah I'm just practicing you don't
do it like exactly simultaneously but
like within a few
you ain't what stood there no I did
that's actually [ __ ]
I like I like [ __ ] maintain how do I
get this just [ __ ] them up for now or
have them like swing in it yep
don't miss I [ __ ] oh I'm gonna stop
you don't don't think the body's gonna
break some change I don't want you to
die thinking that's gonna work
alright I'm just looking shoot him in
the face
wait so you don't worry about the body
line just shooting yeah you got him
daga Hey okay now shoot that shoot yeah
shoot that
he's going piccata so what shotgun go
grab the other one when you can yeah
grab it now stun him with the body
what now stun him with the bodies oh I
see you every time you attack him he's
he's not gonna like stop attacking okay
yeah yeah yeah talking about hold it
you get pulled are to come on
now you're good you're good today not do
it
yeah yeah yeah yeah
they get him do that hit that thing hold
our RN LT R and L hold R and L to NASA
but just keep doing what you're doing
get him want to get out of there
I don't feel like I'm hitting you are
Oh
yeah yeah now our to an LP so hard to
know if I'm hitting it you are you are
I'm really glad this brick is here
that brick is my saving grace
yeah well get to know
Oh duck did he phone keep going keep
going keep going
are you okay oh [ __ ] what you ran out of
bed you're fine you ready to hit him
again what your tape it aren't you out
there you hurt me thank you God
regenerate that [ __ ] he is trying Boop
oh my god my opinion not the best boss
fight it's it's very so the the stress
attack you can do and it'll just go
right there is attacks but it's like I
don't know I don't like that boss
I just had a hard time um I didn't feel
like I was hurting him yeah it's not the
best should I look around here first and
stay dead
I didn't know chainsaws to go through it
don't [ __ ] up the chainsaw for yet no
why didn't you get the scissor chainsaw
the head is there anything in here got
the dog head yeah yay now you find that
you might want to use that I'm on yellow
a lot of newspapers pretty bad all right
sweet nice job
do Chinese not bad at all you helped me
but I again it in the in sorry I was
probably guiding you too much but like
why I was glad to I don't think anyone
wants to watch me do the same box like
six I'm not a great boss fight what am i
doing
am I just leaving yeah you need the
snake key to get through that door back
there
so I was thinking does a scorpion keep
some reason so you probably didn't need
that but it's not like you maybe I get
the snake key outside someone don't
attack me I'm so close to you to leave
the house finally if all goes according
to plan
okay so oh there's a [ __ ] dude out
there remember
yes out he'll no no okay so don't even
worry about just avoid him
don't waste ammo if you if you don't
think you're gonna come down so you're
saying he'll and then run like hell you
might not even have to use the heal if
you're okay and there's not always a guy
at the same spot I'm just trying to
remember where I'm going go for that
light oh god run
okay and then we're okay go left then
right and then left eventually Oh Lord
no that's child child no [ __ ] it gam-gam
oh okay so save think you need the
scoreboard pretty positive you know I'm
gonna save okay so you want to kill
gam-gam
and try with don't freeze now you're
good just heal honestly
I mean I saved wait wait hon you got
items to move around you went outside
this is uncharted territory
right I got everything I need give her
this Gordon can you don't yet if I get a
chem fluid I can make ya one of these
bad boys or one of these bad boys uh I
got a decent amount of bullets actually
then I got health
all right so you and me gam-gam
I hate her
oh my god you suck
[ __ ] her oh my god my going left or
right I can't remember oh god oh god I
put that dog [ __ ] god bless america
yeah I'm out of the house what's that
noise violins
Halo theme yes this is so validating
[Music]
oh this is a big-ass house with an ass
house I know from other knowledge that
these trailers are safe this is like a
safe house was that I already have a gun
that's weird
Wow look at all this stuff
wait oh this is locked steroids okay but
I need a lock pick or wait
but these coins is that what that is
that's so cool
wait hold on look through all your
options first what do you mean you don't
have to do an order you just need a
certain number you need five for this
one three for the other one you need
five coins to open this yeah what is
that safe stable
reloading speed I didn't know that's
what that was I'm glad you stopped me I
was about to just go to nuts there my
body's feeling weirder and weirder soon
I'll become like mom and bap dad it's
all her fault should I run no I can't
I'm dead if she finds out that woman she
was with Mia she knows something if I
had the serum I could cure myself I have
to find out more
god I hate those that family a little
too late for them that's the dad and the
mom and Mia my girlfriend and then I
don't know who the boy is is that right
the boy is a he was at the dinner
who's that one ooh what's this
44 Magnum ooh a magnum and a tape thing
not any new ones
before you save here yeah I'll say this
wait I'll check that I'll check out the
brazier good now that you did that the
backyard where you're around is safe and
also there's a lot of stuff to just like
just cabbage so maybe I should just hang
out yeah
hey hey I'm at the front door Senora
cheese you made it you're the first I've
ever seen make it this far to do is it
gonna help me get out of here
yes now listen carefully Ethan my family
and I our bodies are contaminated I
can't believe the property unless I get
it out and the same goes for Mia is
there a way to get it out we need to
serum
it should clear whatever this stuff is
out of the body as long as you're not
too far gone all right so where is it I
knew where one was I'd already be long
gone but I have a feeling my mother has
hidden some inside the old house am I
talking to you again so so if we get
this thing I can help me and we can get
out of here right and so can I the old
house is near the water
he can't miss it all right I just hope
you can handle my mother your mother be
careful they'll be looking for you
[Music]
okay to be fair I probably live out here
too if that was my house so you're
saying don't save yet and I mean you can
I'm just saying like it's worth
scrounging the backyard okay or you
could do that the beginning of next
episode it's up to you um yeah I mean I
want to keep going okay until you yell
at me I'm not gonna yell at you we are
recording in the middle of a day and
other people might do this room yeah
well they definitely must scavenge
background a little bit Derek's my
backyard okay maybe I should take one of
those things the drugs uh yeah could do
that
you may take some drugs just Gavin first
and then yeah I guess so
it would save time weed that dank acid
dank ass I'm gonna plant cool cleaning
up here it's the chem fluid that's hard
to come by you know mm-hmm I feel like
they do that on purpose cuz they want
you to pick between gunpowder
come on
I don't know what that is must need a
keycard there's a hand in there Oh Lord
with that wait a minute
check under the trailer looks like
there's your brilliant man I honestly
can't tell if it's you or like the one
or more stuff under this side I don't
know yeah I'm paranoid you're looking at
stuff I'm not I'm like looking up
because I'm always afraid like jack is
gonna kill me great you'll get jacked
off I believe that's all of our fears
really you see that trailer for a hand
job cabin it's a parody Charlie I think
I don't think it's a real really but
we'll just see we're done
a separating agent I don't know what
that is does that mean that I can turn
it back into chem fluid yeah cool
no but there's description when you get
it you'll see you're not far off in fact
you might be right that's a weird way to
say that there's more steroids increase
your overall health oh right or you
could use all five to do a faster reload
I feel like stare like having more
health is a pretty big deal all right so
what would you like me to do I could eat
these supplements no those aren't can't
eat supplements you gotta eat stimulants
supplements and chem fluid I think
combined to make sense oh this makes a
medicine I'm pretty sure it's yeah make
some psychostimulants if you mix it with
chem fluid you do a psychostimulants and
the psychostimulants are definitely
worth taking back here
all right well I can get that separation
stuff can I get up here no and then
that's where I'm going to meet his mom
right yeah but but I'm not ready no you
get those psychics anyone's what you
mean you use those get them out of your
safe box he used back in the backyard oh
you want to use them now something else
can be combined with some items to
separate the chem fluid from them into a
usable item cool all right so I will get
the psychostimulants is my last one yeah
that's fine you'll find more and then
should I get rid of every things that I
have more room shotgun shells yeah let's
do some drugs oh I hear a bobble head
too walked forward the house did I [ __ ]
up did you use them or no yeah you did
see there's nothing around
yeah just keep off there's something
down there right there
yeah lockpick you didn't even pick it up
you just put the thing back down oh I'll
get it later
I don't want to waste my drugs yelling I
mean there's like something in the
trailer few things in there damn should
I go in there something out here two
down on earth stairs what does that do
if I do enough those in the Magnum that
doesn't count
yeah keep going over this way ish
wasting my drugs there's there's nothing
that's got an antique coin and wasted of
drugs at least there's one that you're
not seeing like there was one under the
porch did you see that there you go this
one's really big
I have a gun oh I found that broken down
[Music]
all right anything else well I have
these drug remnants in my body
I feel like the drugs are gonna wear off
pretty soon I didn't really need drugs
for that one but I found him should I
not go too far how far can I go I go
back to Cali I'd say little house for
next time
my drugs law buy something got all this
money you got six points for fixing
broken firearms and I have one I have a
broken firearm in here it's already in
here oh I can make a new thing neuro
rounds ammo for the grenade launcher
cool psychostimulants sharp it medicine
that temporarily sharpens the senses
making items section easier so it's like
super stimulant no that's what you've
been using oh okay I understand okay um
okay so I was axon your repair kit yeah
there you go you got a much better
handgun I'm 19 yay the only problem is
you still have ten rounds into your
other pistol I don't see how you can
click on it see if you can can you
so it meant like could I pull over near
me l2 and do this yeah yes so and then
yeah neither so win that gun yeah come
on go to your inventory okay click X on
the old hand gun on the old hand gun
you're not not in the not in the box
your inventory oh yeah X on the old hand
gun this one yeah you press square on it
and then go over to the other hand gun
and press play again or that's just
gonna swap them I think yeah you might
have to use those sorry you can have
both of them it's all right now but like
don't reload with the old gun at all
then you're gonna waste bullets right
you guys in the meantime we can look up
let's go shopping
I want to increase my max health do you
think that's reasonable it's only worth
three I'm amazed that a stabilizers
worth more look at my craze like the
more you get used to the game unless
you're gonna get hit just the steroids
are worth getting also something I
forgot to mention it's actually good now
you could get the steroids and then
don't use them yet because they also
heal you so wait until you're in the red
before you upgrade oh I see so it
doubles as a good help
all right I guess that's it for now
right yeah save it up whoo killed that
guy lockpicks you could go a lockpick
something if you wanted to I have that
one lockpick upstairs there's also one
in the room next to the fireplace room
do you think that's worth doing
I save actually might be good to save it
and then that will jog remember next
time if you have a lockpick in your
inventory okay sweet productive episode
poof it wasn't as scary but it was still
really intense lots of nasty little mold
ease yeah what do you uh what am i I
mean it's still tremendous I think I
don't like that Jack bossfight that's
like one of the low points a game oh
really I think it's too scripted it's
pretty I mean it's limited I think the
only thing I wish I had was a better
understanding of like when I was killing
someone like what like what was
happening yeah I say the rest of game is
really good about giving you feedback
unlike rescue six and five of when
you're hurting someone that one it's
because jack is supposed to be really
strong and not feel much pain I think
they just kept kept in bowling full
rushing through your bullets yeah that's
the old house all right
I remember this yeah okay absolutely
okay well happy Thanksgiving weekend I
have people in the US hopefully you got
to join us while you had a few days off
and then people outside of the US
hopefully you're having a great normal
weekend we were you doing we got
holidays coming up in a few weeks it's a
name of the year yeah and we'll probably
breeze through a lot of reading will
seven in the coming weeks
creased mass because the DLC is coming
out mid-december not a hero dude have
you seen it do you know the details of
it you don't know okay cool I'm
impressed
it surprised but I won't say anything
sweet
yes everybody thank you guys for
watching next week that noise concerning
because I'm concerned you're gonna keep
doing that